you need some great gifting ideas maybe
for some family members or your friends
something fun to play
after dinner during the holidays well
kirsten joyce joining us now with some
help with that
denise we caught up with lifestyle and
parenting expert amanda mushroom
who gave us an awesome top five games
the year for a variety of ages that can
all be found on amazon
the first is called what's wrong with
grown-ups it's great for tweens and
teens and adults you can get a bunch of
questions in to get you all
sharing the next is for those of you who
like puzzle games it's called sagrada
you're an artesian who's been
commissioned to create a stained glass
window it's a strategy game that's
different every time you play
the next is called incoherent family
this one is so much fun so easy to play
so the idea is you hold up these
cards and they're going to have just
gibberish written on the cards
and you're just going to say it over and
over until everybody figures out
what they're saying so this one says bin
jo
wad shin and it's actually binge
watching so it's just it's kind of this
gibberish phrasing there's some clues
that they can figure out what what the
actual word is what i like about this
it's
pop culture references just different
cliches and words that people know
this one you will definitely be loling
at the table
all right for the gamer in your life
there's prisma arena board game
and finally fog of love this is a
grown-up game for date night it's a
romantic comedy board game
where you have two crazy characters put
in some crazy situations and at the end
you have to find out if they
stay together or break up so there are
some ideas for you